I think Nagisa's knife will hit it, it's impossible.
Hey, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, look,
for Takaoka, this match is
a battle to show off.
What does that mean?
If you don't work with a
real knife, you'll die.
I hesitated
and remembered Mr. Karasuma's advice
That's right
It doesn't matter if you fight or not If you
kill, you win
Articles, etc.
I was about to be killed, and I was
startled and lost my balance
.
I thought it
would be blocked, so I
definitely set up
4 Ah, hmm,
what a thing. It far exceeded my expectations. A talent
that will never be discovered in a normal life.
A talent for letting
go, when I'm not afraid of chaos,
that's what I felt in my training
.